[DIGITAL EFFECT]
SPEAKER 1: (SINGING)
Your birthday, boy.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Google
Kubernetes Engine turns five!
Yeah!
Happy birthday, GKE.
What is GKE?
It is the first cloud-based
managed Kubernetes service.
And as we celebrate
GKE's fifth birthday,
let's take a little journey
through the five things
that we all love
so much about it.
First off, GKE is easy to use.
We all know that Kubernetes
is the de facto standard
for container orchestration.
But we also know that it can get
complex to operate and manage.
That's where GKE comes in.
It takes away the complexity
out of Kubernetes,
by providing a robust command
line interface and easy
to use UI to manage all your
containers in one place.
It manages DNS, networking,
traffic management,
and load balancing,
amongst other things.
And it works across a lot of
simple and complex use cases,
including Linux, Windows,
stateful, stateless,
existing or new apps and single
or multi tier cluster apps.
Second is trust.
Once you develop
and deploy the app,
you have complete control to
manage that GKE environment.
You get the choice
to automatically
upgrade and repair them
if something goes wrong,
without worrying about
availability, because Google
site reliability engineers
constantly monitor
your cluster and its
computing, networking,
and storage resources.
With release channels,
you get the freedom
to choose the Kubernetes
version of your choice.
You can choose the
cutting-edge latest release
version in the Rapid channel, or
choose the most tested version
in the Stable channel.
Or be in between in
the Regular channel.
Next is best price
to performance.
When you use GKE, you get
the best value for your money
because it does offer the
lowest cost to performance ratio
for running the
containerized applications.
It offers four-way
industry's first auto-scaling
to optimize resources
when you scale up and down
your apps based on your needs.
For advanced apps, you can
use application accelerators,
like GPUs and TPUs on GKE.
And it helps kickstart your
hybrid and multi-cloud journey.
Next, and very
important, is BeyondProd,
the cloud-native
security approach.
With strong security defaults,
GKE offers cluster security
beyond platform hardening
and OS patching.
The clusters in GKE natively
support Kubernetes network
policy to restrict traffic
with pod level firewall rules.
You can verify,
enforce and improve
the security of infrastructure
components and packages used
for your container images.
With the sandbox feature,
you get a second layer
of defense between
containerized workloads
on GKE for enhanced
workload security.
You also get built-in
support for a wide range
of compliance standards.
In short, you get
BeyondProd security,
Google's cloud-native security
approach for your workloads.
And we are on number five.
What's needed to
navigate change?
The only constant
in our lives, scale.
Whether you want to simplify
your infrastructure management,
have batch processing
needs, or simply looking
to run internet scale apps and
absorb large spikes in traffic,
with GKE, you are in luck.
Because starting with
1.18, GKE provides
the most supported nodes of any
cloud-based Kubernetes service.
And three times
the number of nodes
supported by open
source Kubernetes.
How's that for five in five?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Are you ready to get started?
To celebrate GKE's
fifth birthday,
we've got something
special for you.
Check out this
link to learn more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]